for some god-awful reason my wife who I
still love dearly brought this toy home
for our kids
now this is the sound this is
[Music]
[Music]
this is the sound of this toy mix and
and and and so the first thing that I
did when when I when she brought the
store home is I threw it in the garbage
but then my kids went on went and told
on me to mommy and mommy rescued it from
the garbage and so I've had to listen to
this sound day and night and you know
what's gonna happen right because every
parent knows what happens at a certain
point in a toys old age as its spirits
weakens it becomes possessed by two
thousand demons and then it starts going
off at random points even when no one's
touching it and so what's gonna happen
is one night I'm gonna wake up and I'm
gonna hear this sound coming from
downstairs and I'm gonna think that a
which is being stabbed to death in the
living room because that's what I always
assume when there's a when there's a
sound at night but no it's gonna be this
toy and this is one of the many many
reasons why I hate noisy toys I mean my
son somehow smuggled a toy police car
that makes a siren noise and I thought I
had taken the batteries out of all those
things because he has 15 of them but I
smuggled one of them into the car and
then set it off as we were driving down
the highway so I had a nice little
moment of panic because of that now
listen I believe that marriage is a
lifelong monogamous Union and that we
must remain united as a couple so I will
not blame my wife for buying this I will
it's possible that she suffered a
momentary bout of insanity it's possible
that aliens hijacked her brain I try to
see the best in my wife and so that's
what I'm gonna do here but I'll say this
when I am dictator of the world which I
promise you I will be soon enough I'm
going to shut down every toy company
that has ever produced a noisy toy for
children and every store that has ever
sold one and then I'm going to
confiscate all those noisy toys and I'm
going to burn them in a massive fire and
I will invite all of the world's parents
except my wife to come and and dance
joyously around the flames and as we
dance and dance and dance this is the
sound that they're going to make as they
burn
[Music]
[Music]
and we will laugh together amen
all right now I want to follow up on so
don't buy noisy toys for your kids is
what I'm trying to say or especially
right what I mean to say is as we head
into the holiday season don't buy no
noisy toys for someone else's kids
especially because that is well it's it
frankly sinful I believe now I want to
follow up on something from yesterday we
we talked about the Gosnell film and how
it's being hijacked or I should say how
it's being blackballed by the media and
the movie theaters and it's being
ignored by the left and I said that the
left is terrified of Gosnell terrified
of Gosnell the person and Gosnell the
movie and all of events surrounding
Gosnell that they're terrified of that
story in general because of the
implications because they realize that
if you would if you actually investigate
this case and if you think about it for
even if you pause for even a moment to
think about it you'll begin to see that
there is no basis upon which to oppose
Gosnell unless you oppose all abortion
and that's a problem because I mean
almost any thinking person any person
with a soul when you read about the
Gosnell case you can't help but be
horrified and say this man deserves to
rot in prison or worse but then if you
if you think just one more moment you
begin to ask yourself well what really
is the difference between what Gosnell
did and and what a normal abortionist
does yes he killed babies moments after
they were born most abortionist kill
them moments before but so what murder
is murder dead is dead the child is just
as dead either way
it's it's it's it is an act of violence
either way it's the same act of violence
against the same person what does it
matter you know where they are located
whether inside the womb or outside of it
when that act of violence and murder
occurs so just to elaborate on that I
would like to propose one of two things
okay and I know that neither of these
things will actually happen but I'm just
trying to make a point here I
opposed that and here's my preference
okay here's here's one option one option
is that all abortionists are locked in a
cage that they're all sent to prison I
think that's the best option second
option is that Gosnell is allowed to go
free because I think they all should be
treated the same as a matter of as a
matter of honesty really as a matter of
justice and honesty and and and and you
know forcing us as a society to confront
what we're actually permitting and
tolerating we should treat all these
people the same because they are all the
same they they are the same they're when
it comes to abortion there are only two
intellectually honest positions that you
can have okay one is and this is this is
the intellectually honest and also
morally correct position and that is you
can be totally opposed to abortion in
every situation no matter the
circumstances period that's one option
that's intellectually consistent and and
also morally correct the second option
is you could be totally in favor of
abortion through all stages up to birth
and even then at least maybe two years
beyond birth that is intellectually
consistent it's morally depraved but
it's intellectually consistent you know
I think the Peter Singer has the right
idea here Peter singers a prominent
atheist philosopher and he said that he
has said multiple times that he thinks
abortion should extend beyond birth and
he gives a very logical reason he says
that there is really no substantive
difference between a newborn and a Nana
and a quote unquote fetus so whatever
argument justifies the killing of a
quote unquote fetus should [ __ ] can also
be applied to the new to newborn
children I mean think about it there are
only two arguments that are that can be
really be used to justify pre birth
abortion they're both bad arguments but
there are only two arguments one is that
a mother shouldn't be forced to care
a child and and second the second
argument is that an unborn child is not
the same as a born child well on the
first point a newborn child is just as
dependent physically on his mother as he
was in the womb he needs constant
attention he needs he needs constant
physical contact newborn children it's
not just like they you know the the the
child emerges from the womb and then
he's a self-sustaining human they can
take care of it no he needs constant
attention needs physical contact if a
newborn child does not have physical
contact with his mother or with someone
he could die so and in fact a newborn
child makes a route makes
round-the-clock demands on his mother he
is quite a bit more demanding outside of
the womb than he was inside it and
anyone who has ever had a newborn child
knows this where the child makes a
constant demand on your body on your
time on your money on your attention on
everything your entire life now revolves
around this child as it stands we
require a mother by law to care for her
child or else make arrangements for
someone else to do it it but if she
can't find someone else and she's
struggling to care for her child we
absolutely do not allow her to kill her
child now this to me seems completely
inconsistent with the bodily autonomy
arguments that we use to justify pre
birth abortion if we're saying if we are
saying to a mother with a newborn child
that you're supposed bodily autonomy
rights while you may have them they do
not give you the right to kill a person
and and even though you have those
rights you alt because you are the
mother of the child you have a legal you
have a moral and legal obligation to
care for that child
or else find someone who will you can
not kill the child not only do you have
a legal and more obligation to your
child but you have a legal and moral
obligation that nobody else in the world
does you have a unique aside from the
father it if he's in the picture which
he should be so as as a parent you have
a unique obligation legally to that
child that's what we say to the mother
after immediately after birth that's
what we say to the mother if we're going
to say it to her immediately after birth
then there's no reason at all why we
shouldn't say it to her while the bit
before birth as well so if we're going
to say before birth that that you can
exercise this autonomy even up to the
point of murdering your child then
there's really actually no reason and
there's no logical basis upon which we
can we can penalize mothers who kill
their born children so you know by that
that logic applies to both now the
second point we say well the unborn baby
is not the same as a born one well in
what way is that true in terms of
physical development if that's what
you're hinging this on well then at most
you could possibly support his first
trimester abortions of if you support
abortion based on physical development
then the most you could possibly get
away with his first trimester abortions
because a baby
midway through the second trimester can
survive outside the womb he has all of
his organs his limbs his heart his brain
his eyes everything he has all the same
parts as a born baby and if you could
abort him anyway then why can't you
abort a born baby and in fact even
babies in the first trimester yes they
don't have all of the physical
development yet but but babies who are
born also aren't fully physically
developed either they can't walk they
can't talk they don't have hardly any
fine motor skills at all and so on so
the matter how no matter how you look at
it this
applies to both the born and the unborn
and then there's the other measure you
know consciousness and this is what
Peter Singer points to he says that
unborn babies do not have moral standing
as people because they have no
self-awareness they have no concept of
themselves they don't know what's going
on of course there's no way for us to
really be sure of that we only assume it
because we have no memories from the
womb and so we assume that if you aren't
forming and collecting memories then you
must not really be conscious so so
singer he takes that standard and he and
it's a horrific standard a terrible
standard but he applies it equally and
he says that well a newborn infant also
does isn't very conscious probably has
less consciousness than a monkey or a
pig same for people in a coma same for
people who are very old and very sick in
nursing homes same for same for the
mentally is some who are mentally
disabled people in all of these
categories also we could argue some of
them don't have much consciousness
although we don't know how much they
actually do have so Peter Singer says
well abort all of them you know they
could all be killed now again that's
horrific that's morally deranged but
it's logically consistent what you can't
do
logically is apply that standard or any
of these standards arbitrarily to the
unborn as if they're unique in all of
these ways because they aren't they the
unborn children belong to a certain
category of existence and it is a rather
crowded category that is the category is
defenseless wholly dependent limited in
mental and physical capacity humans
that's the category they belong to and
it is on that basis that they are
defenseless wholly dependent limited in
mental or physical capacity that's the
basis upon which we we we we we justify
abortion
well except that as I said that is a
category that includes a lot of other
people aside from just the unborn so it
is morally abominable to advocate for
killing all of the people in this
category but it's morally abominable and
logically inconsistent to advocate for
killing only one of the subgroups within
that larger group so the point is
Gosnell expanded his reach a little bit
okay
he took the abortion philosophy he took
the abortion rationale and he simply
applied it to newborn kids so morally
he's not any different than any other
abortionist and morally what he did is
not any different from abortion it's
just a form of abortion that's all
intellectually he's actually more honest
and more consistent than your average
abortion or your average your average
abortionist or your average pro-abortion
person so we have to decide okay are we
going to be the kind of society that
punishes those who kill the helpless and
the innocent are we going to be that
kind of society or not but I think we
have to choose you know I don't think we
should have it both ways if we're if we
are going to be the kind of society that
will tolerate and even celebrate and
certainly defend the the systematic
slaughter of unborn children if we're
gonna be this kind of society that can
look at 60 million murdered unborn
children and we're gonna look at that
and we're just gonna yawn at it and
shrug our shoulders and say who cares if
that's going to be the kind of society
that we are then we don't deserve to put
Kermit Gosnell in prison
I mean where do we get off putting
someone like Gosnell in prison all of
the all of the bloodshed and murder and
violence that we tolerate and celebrate
and justify and we think we have the
right to be to be what morally indignant
because a guy killed kill babies a few
seconds after they were born now we have
no right to that just like we have no
right to you know you hear these
horrible cases of mothers that give
birth to babies throw them in dumpsters
throw them in a toilet here but I mean I
think about Andrea Yates she drowned
five whatever five or six of her kids
and in bathtubs we really have as a
society we have no moral right actually
to judge any of those people if we're
gonna justify the murder of 60 million
kids and say that all of that's
perfectly fine well then who are we to
say oh well except for that murder well
that's wrong no we need to decide I
think I think we should have to confront
either we're the kind of either either
murder is illegal or it ISM you know
what that's what it is
either either we're gonna say that
murder is illegal or not we got to
choose which is it and if we're saying
that murder isn't illegal well then fine
just open up the floodgates I guess it
should be the purge murders not you know
human life is not sacred because that's
what you're saying really when it comes
down to it if abortion is is is legal
and fine and morally acceptable that
human life is not sacred human life is
not it doesn't mean anything so let
Gosnell out of prison let them all out
of prison let all the murderers out or
put them all in lets choose
what kind of society do we want to be
you know III think that people who
support abortion they know at some level
that that their position is morally
atrocious at some level they must know
if they have a soul if they have any
kind of human conscience left within
them which may be which some of them may
be doubt but but those who do they know
at some level that abortion is a
horrible atrocity but they try to
convince themselves that they still have
moral standards bye-bye you know
although they they they tolerate they
accept this kind of murder well then
they'll turn around and condemn other
forms of murder as a way of kind of
hiding from themselves of hiding from
their own position trying to convince
themselves that they have moral
standards well I you know I just I don't
think we should allow them to do that
let me have the courage of your
convictions if you're Pro murder then
just be Pro murder all right one other
point I want to hit on here switching
gears there were there were protests
yesterday yes protests if you can
believe it I mean it had been probably
six or seven hours since the last one so
we needed a good protest but these
protests were aimed at Donald Trump
because news broke that the Trump
administration is considering defining
gender as as as based on your biological
sex at birth the horror what a horrible
thing right and the point of making this
completely reasonable and necessary
change is for title nine purposes and
when assessing discrimination complaints
and so on and so forth so so what the
what the administration wants to say is
well you're you know male or female
those are the two categories and that's
determined anatomically biologically
that's that's the the change that the
Trump administration wants to make but
the left which has descended completely
and irretrievably into anti science
if ik madness insists that sex has
nothing to do with biology at all so
they are very upset about this in fact
the New York Times The New York Times
Science Twitter page tweeted out an
article today with this headline this is
the headline it says the idea that a
person's sex is determined by their
their Anatomy at birth is not true and
we've known that it's not true for
decades and then they and then the
article gets into this whole scientific
explanation as to why the biological sex
essentially doesn't exist now look at
what they're doing here okay there's
always a slippery slope with these
people and and and you know you should
really pay attention to this because
they used to say that sex is biological
but gender is a spectrum which was crazy
enough now they say that both of them
are a spectrum have you noticed that
change is a very important change and it
may have been kind of subtle you may not
have noticed but for a long time it was
well you know there's a difference
between sex and gender
that's what they used to say they
invented this concept of gender as
distinct from sex so as to introduce the
idea of spectrums into the into the
conversation and now they're reverting
back to sex and gender being
interchangeable concepts and both of
them now are are our spectrums gender by
the way is a it was originally a
grammatical term gender denotes that a
word is masculine or feminine which
doesn't come up much in modern English
but in other languages it does so
leftist they took that grammatical
concept and they applied it to humans
they turned it into an actual state of
being pretending that you had that a
person has both a sex and a gender as
two distinct things but now it which was
which was crazy and makes no sense but
now they're there they're merging the
two again it seems so so this is what I
want to
okay and I gotta spend a lot of time on
it but this is what I'll say to those
many millions of confused and deluded
people who insist that sex is a spectrum
to insist that it isn't binary well you
know what I could be convinced right now
I think you're crazy I think what you're
saying is anti-science madness and I
think you're totally completely wrong
and and you lack even a first graders
understanding of basic sine that's what
I think now but you could convince me
that I'm wrong you could convince me
that that sex isn't is not binary this
way it's very it's very simple this is
all you have to do to convince me and I
think this is this is how you could
convince a lot of people all you have to
do is find one example just one in all
of human history just one example of a
person who could get pregnant and also
impregnate others okay find me someone
just one person out of the seven billion
in the world or the or the or the or the
billions more who have existed
throughout human history find me just
one person who has the ability to
conceive and fertilize in other words
find me someone with the functioning
reproductive organs of both sexes if sex
is not binary you should be able to find
me a person like that in fact you should
be able to find me a lot of people like
that but you can't find one can you out
of the ten billion whatever people who
have existed on planet Earth you cannot
find me one person like that can you do
you know why because there are only two
categories of people when it comes to
sex there aren't three there are ten
there aren't an infinite number there
are only two categories and those
categories are very simply those who get
pregnant
and those who impregnate those are the
two categories that's huh
those are the only categories when it
comes to sex that's it that's all you
got and they are not interchangeable
there is no spectrum between them those
are every person who has ever existed on
earth is in this category or that one
that's it now you can call those
categories anything you want okay you
don't have to call them man or women and
men you don't have to do that you can
call them whatever you call them
blah-dee-blah and yada Yas whatever you
want to call them doesn't matter but
there are only two categories okay and
that's all there is to it if it is
impossible if it is absolutely
impossible for a person with functioning
male sex organs to also have functioning
female sex organs then it is impossible
for a man to be a woman period end of
story
that's all I'm sorry I'm sorry if you
don't like it I'm sorry for hurts your
feelings I'm sorry if you feel
differently but you're simply wrong
because facts are facts now yes of
course I know I know what people are
gonna say you know well what about
infertile people what about people who
are sterile what about people who can't
do either of those things there are
people who can't get pregnant or
impregnate well yes but that yes those
people exist but they don't change the
principle okay such people are suffering
from illness or deformity that doesn't
change the principle in principle men
impregnate and women get pregnant that's
the principle and sickness old-age and
deformity
they don't change that in fact if a
young woman can't get pregnant we know
that something is wrong that there's
been an aberration of some kind how do
we know that something is wrong because
we know that all women are supposed to
be able to get pregnant so if there's a
woman who can't that's how we know that
something is wrong
which which by the way if sex is really
a spectrum if it's not binary then
there's no reason to assume that there's
anything physically wrong with a woman
who who can't get pregnant but we know
that there is something wrong because in
principle this is a capacity that women
have in the same way if a man is born
with one arm that doesn't mean that he's
a new type of human being he hasn't
proven that there's a whole new
fundamental category of people who are
one-armed no we know that if a man is
born with one arm we know that something
is wrong he is from the two arm category
because that's the only category that
exists for people but something went
wrong and so now there's no arm where
the arm ought to be but the existence of
one-armed people and to arm people that
does not change the fact that in
principle human beings possess two arms
if you were to tell your child to draw a
picture of a person it and and and
they'd draw a creature that has five
arms or no arms you're gonna say no
that's not you know people have two arms
with the exception of sickness deformity
mutation people have two arms in
principle just as in principle women get
pregnant men and pregnant if sex is a
spectrum if it's not binary if it's
possible to change your sex you should
be able to find me one person just one
with the reproductive capacities of both
sexes but you can't and you never will
you know with the exception of in the
future if if science finds a way to
create Frankenstein monsters where they
could take a uterus out of a woman and
put it into a man which who knows maybe
one day they'll be able to do that but
that's not going to change the principle
now you're just going to have a
Frankenstein you gonna have a monster
now that's all you have you're not going
to have a man with the natural capacity
to conceive children so that's all you
know I can't believe that we have to
have this conversation but we do and
that right there that's the end of the
discussion you cannot unless you can
find me that person who can get
themselves pregnant essentially unless
you can find me that person
you simply cannot ever say that that sex
is non-binary because I have just
explained to you what the binary system
is and in order to prove that it's
non-binary you have to find me someone
who exists in you know you'd have to
prove that this is kind of like a Venn
diagram and in that there are people who
exist in that middle circle who have
both capacities but you can't so sex is
binary that's all glad we could
establish that thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed